ah hey everybody today is a day of
Technology hating me I've got that I've
got this going because I used my
freaking phone to actually stream from
but I usually monitor the chat on my
laptop which is currently spinning with
the blue screen saying just a moment
like my old days been like this I got
into work
Oh God's sake this stupid friggin thing
is that plugged in properly
that better be hang on a second is that
actually ah I just got a battery warning
on my phone I'm wondering if it's
actually plugged in if it's actually
charging the way it's supposed to sorry
hang on annoyingly I'm not drinking this
time they'd be justified under the
circumstances oh yeah I'll show you the
earrings in a second they're one of the
things I got what ah hi everybody
so yeah the earrings these were sent to
me off my wishlist
um forgive me I am going to forget a lot
of who sent me what and I am also not
going to remember everything that I was
sent or received because I'd like my
memory is crap I eat is legitimately
crap so if I don't name if I show
something that somebody sent me and I
don't name who was from I'm sorry but I
guarantee you that's gonna happen it's
gotta be a big part of what I mean I
just call
at the last livestream of the year
because it's factually accurate I've
never seen JoJo's Bizarre Adventure but
um I just was I couldn't say Oh one of
the main thing I was gonna do with this
was to show off the stuff I got over the
holidays so you know the earrings the
gloves actually these were my stocking
the shirt metal not in the affairs of
dragons for your crunchy and good with
ketchup the the flannel shirt I also got
and I can show this off this I got
actually only the other day so this is
from this designed by Jackson bird and
it is it's sort of the Deathly Hallows
but its flipped upside down with trans
stuff worked into it as well I thought
you said the QA was the last livestream
so happy there's one more well it was I
I thought it was going to be but then I
realized looking at my schedule like I
could squeeze in one more this was an
original part of my plan my dad has that
shirt with her hidden on it you may have
to make you feel old Thanks
I mean I'm a father too when I should
get used to getting compared to dads I'm
excited to see 13 play poker I don't
know I haven't been I haven't really
been paying attention to like any of the
little drips and dribbles that have been
coming out on what the freakin hell
sorry hold on what is going on
what what what what is no no no no no
sorry that alright just boot up dammit
you
I don't even know how did you describe
those types of gloves steampunk style
faux leather pleather these are very
much pleather
they look good though don't they
ah-ah-ah
okay I'll be able to catch up and
actually keep tabs on this on the stream
in a minute because like I'm getting the
live scroll on the phone but I'm you
know these they scroll pass quickly and
then I can't see them anymore
all right so here's this there's that
huh so oh all right I've got so I I am
not drinking this time however I have a
different little bit of fundraising fun
a co-worker coworker actually gave me
two things they gave me this which is a
notebook which makes it my second Harry
Potter themed notebook why why did that
just go away
ah ah ticking me off um
what is going on with my computer I can
already tell there's gonna be the
running theme of the entire thing why
did why did that just go in sleep mode
I am a jinx on technology I don't know
if I've mentioned that before but that's
part of the reason that I am so slow to
update to new tech and I will run my
stuff into the ground because it is
going to screw up on me in weird and
unique ways and it's somehow more
frustrating for that to happen to me on
something I just bought as opposed to
something that I know is old and has
every right to fail it doesn't owe me
anything anymore I hate buying new tech
stuff because it's going to screw up on
me in weird bizarre ways that nobody can
ever account for like I'm not gonna say
that that these things fail on me in
ways that they that are impossible
they're obviously possible to happen to
me but like I'll look up solutions like
oh just do this well I can't because
this thing isn't functioning oh well
that's not normal
that's Matt's my life in technology and
now this friggin huh okay what is I am
gonna have to replace this laptop at
some point it is not new it is uh yeah
and I do feel a little bit like the guy
from Good Omens
anyways why is it mmm I can't even get
the dang thing to reboot properly right
now what is ah okay is this is this now
working Yes No maybe go to hell huh
perks of being married to a tech him
hagas yeah you're very lucky
I don't like computers they're rough
hard and of course they get sick
freeware yes that is exactly so the
other thing my coworker gave me was
Bertie Botts every flavor beans so last
last livestream I took a shot for every
certain amount of super chat sent my way
this time how many of these are there in
this thing so everyone - I don't know
how many there are in here but what I
what I'm gonna do this time because I'm
not drinking I think I have stuff to do
after those live streams over for every
super chat donation
I will blindly pick out one every flavor
bean I am gonna use the guide to figure
out what the heck I just picked but
whatever it is I will eat it so there's
our little crowdfunding way you can
torture me this time so you can't make
me drunk this time but maybe you can
make me vomit or at least taste a beam
that is flavored like vomit awesome side
view on the pictures you posted on
Instagram of my own words too hot for
YouTube also got some headway slippers
and they are awesome very cool yeah a
lot of em a lot of the stuff that goes
up on the Instagram is uh would get me
swiftly demonetized on this platform
yeah that's what you get with the with
the varied interests my mother gave me
those Bertie Botts for Christmas she
never gives me phantom related stuff so
yeah oh that's cool
if you were complaining to the doctor
which doctor would you travel with I
traveled with 13 and she's my favorite
doctor I mean probably 11 I think we'd
get along the best even though 11 isn't
my favorite doctor you've done right
the doctors conveniens masters and
tortoises will you ever do a ranking of
the site yeah eventually
but the which list or ranking video I do
is voted on by the patreon supporters I
give them some options and they pick
which one they want me to do sonic
screwdrivers has been offered a few
times they've opted for other stuff so
I'm sure I'll get to it eventually ah
alas earwax best quote from Harry Potter
ah did you watch The Witcher yet oh my
god Oh like between the holidays and me
trying to get caught up cuz I've
honestly have been behind on my schedule
since the summer it's just uh no I
haven't I would like to but I haven't I
thought we had a sonic list no ranking
the doctors here oh boy here we go thank
yous and dear let's get this started no
thing I wanted to say thanks for putting
my doll and explaining your shelf there
I hope you have a Merry Christmas
yes yeah that's okay so well I dropped
one I don't know where it one so I'm not
gonna dig for it oh it's blue what might
that be that might be blueberry it might
be watermelon I think the blue ones are
fairly safe that's blueberry cool
blueberry is a flavor that should happen
more actually in candies mandalorian
family yes I need to get to that too and
then figure out if I'm gonna do an
overall review of the season um ever
gonna go to galaxy's edge I heard it's
really good I have no idea man I can't
afford to go to Disney World
Thank You Sophie I'm tired before it but
before I go eat a bean all right
pink wonderful boy what are the
possibilities of pink it's probably
candy floss yeah
I'm looking out so far that luck won't
hold have you ever seen a show called
The Inbetweeners no but I've heard of it
haha okay hashtag make Joel a moderator
alright alright alright here you go my
friend you've more than earned it
actually meant to do it before but there
we go
Fox on cats Mickey seven million that's
my thoughts on Kathleen seven billion
who thought that was gonna make its
money back for the way they chose to
make it oh my god most anticipated
release of 2020 not gonna answer that
cuz there's gonna be a video with that
exact topic next week week after next
week or two just dropped out of the man
and high castle for this live stream
hello oval welcome Cassie probably
nostalgia for the Broadway show the
thing the thing is a concept like cats
only works on stage I would actually
argue it doesn't work at all I don't get
the appeal of the stage show but at the
very least what I will grant cats is
that on a stage see live the spectacle
of it and seeing the the dance and the
movement especially being performed at
that level in front of your eyes by real
human beings going wow what amazing
things the human body is capable of and
such beauty and movement is completely
lost when you do it on film because a
the the exact same things can be
accomplished with camera trickery and be
you replace the ball with CGI cats so it
doesn't look real anyways what were they
thinking will you watch the news side
movie when it comes out
maybe if I need a laugh
Donna ranked lightsabers or something
like that I mean probably not I'm not
sure I died I'm invested enough in the
minor differences in handle
a half dozen different colors we've
actually seen on film I wish I smoked
too wheeze cuz it would love to watch
cats while super high I actually would
be terrified to watch cats while on
anything even vaguely mine defecting
I love you and crispy pros who to rewind
video that was a lot of fun
I like crispy and I like um I like his
sense of humor so that was that was good
stuff
I've tried the Harry Potter jelly slugs
um excuse me they taste good uh less
likely to get bad flavors no I don't
know them I think a cats movie could
have worked and in live-action too but
how they did it I need a stiff drink
after seeing it and I don't drink
most wasted actor or concept in Doctor
Who
um hmm don't know like I'd have to think
on that which means I'm not gonna get to
it Thank You Erin
let's see what we get that's oh boy
that's white in yellow so that might be
lemon that might be earwax oh I just
drop one too
all right huh we'll see oh oh that's
your wax
Oh
Oh God ah
all right shoulda had some just fit this
out in Oh God
alas earwax Oh
ah do I ever plan to do another
Buffyverse video maybe eventually I'm
sure it's not high on my list because
passion of the nerd is kind of putting
any thoughts that I have to shame at
least this in hot P look here's what I
want to know who are the poor suckers
who have to compete let the taste test
these things compared to the real thing
to ensure that they've got it close
no spit-takes uh I have not committed to
that I'm not promising no spit-takes
some of these if they go bad on me I
might spit them out so I am NOT pledging
no spit-takes I will try because I
didn't and bring anything to spit them
out into um oh I was gonna show you more
stuff that I got alright so what my kid
got me my cup of tea it's actually a
thing for for loose leaves um or you
know could just use it as as any doing
tea mugs so that was really nice I don't
know how well it'll show up on there but
it's kind of got this pearlescent
lighting effect on it which is which is
really cool and very pretty
ah so there's that that was fun because
for some reason I always end up with
random electronic gadgets I now have a
remote control thing which goes stupid
fast this thing like it it's it kind of
scares me how fast this thing goes and
because it's bouncing off walls pretty
much immediately
ah what else we got Oh Oh the most
exciting thing that I got for Christmas
socks lots of socks I don't know why I
felt the need to share that but yeah
this this is fleece-lined
mmm cuz i need somebody to keep my feet
warm when i have to go and shovel if you
could have any convenient return to me
the thirteenth doctor who would you want
to return I think au s-- would be cool
ace is probably top of my list right now
I got the invisibility cloak for
Christmas how how would we know I got
socks too based on ass bro cakes uh okay
what else have I got
oh I got I got an aloe body bar yes I'm
sharing with you the boring stuff -
don't you feel fortunate
oh this was exciting should they make a
dogs movie Andrew go on the corner think
about what you just did this was
exciting for me I a unicorn snot
this stuff's great this is uh this is
glitter gel which should be in the
repertoire of any burlesque dancer or
stripper or pole dancer or anyone who's
gonna be exposing a fair amount of skin
should have this on hand you don't
always want to use it sometimes Sparkle
isn't what you're going for but good
stuff good stuff to have did you know
they really have an invisibility cloak
in the Harry Potter Museum excuse me in
London I didn't even know there was a
Harry Potter museum and now get hiccups
this this is this is my life somehow
already on it should I write lines with
um bridges pen - don't tempt me so I
sent this from Nick
this this is the Joker as seen from
Justice League action and fairly
poseable as well although I will admit
it disturbs me slightly that his hands
are in this motion and he can so easily
be set up with his hands like right
there yeah they hmm
I feel like somebody didn't really think
too hard about about designing this
thing off-topic question is Attack of
the Clones more enjoyable bad than the
Phantom Menace The Phantom Menace is
taking me of my brother multiple days to
finish I actually don't know Attack of
the Clones is the only Star Wars movie
no it's one of two Star Wars movies that
I have only seen once the other being
the last Jedi there's a scene in Casper
you can hear dogs barking in another
room and now I'm just walking away
wondering what on earth are supposed to
look like in this monster reality haha
what's your Instagram my Instagram is
very wild I don't have council of geeks
on Instagram somebody else has it but
very wild ve Rawi lde because i had to
spell it soup or pretentious would you
like to suggest a better more
interesting plot for cats no cuz cats
doesn't have a plot that's another thing
that you can really only kind of get
away with in theater to just immerse
yourself in the experience for two hours
and not need a plot or character arcs or
anything that we would normally
associate with good storytelling you
can't get away with that in film you
really can't how do you watch Doctor Who
on ketchup do you have BBC iPlayer in
the US I do not I too need to I'm pretty
sure I'm gonna have to subscribe to
HBO's new thing to get Doctor Who so
that'll be fun cats act horny and ascend
to the end Cass 2019
gasps movies looks freakish people joke
that furries made it but let's face it
the designs would have been much better
and less horrifying your furries
designed them I bet I would bet money
that a lot of furries would say this
movie gives them a bad name I've been
watching the New Adventures of Winnie
the Pooh it's actually far better than I
remember it I remember that being quite
good um cuz Ben frigging whoever classic
who is on Brit bucks I know that I have
Brit box
shouldn't Star Wars be remade starring
cats
oh god you you people are gonna give me
nightmares bless your hearts all of you
but seriously uh speaking as a fairy I
can say that most of us hate the cats
movie just just like you normies good to
know I suspected as much
the cats in the film look almost as
disgusting as the original sonic design
at least the original sonic sign didn't
act horny on top of everything else we
need a Muppets Star Wars movie ooh
they could do that too
cuz Disney owns both of them at this
point can I come out of the corner now
yes but you have to behave okay new
movie you make idea Joker but with cats
so it wouldn't be Joker it would be
grumpy cat the movie opinion on the
curse child
Jonathan Carlin says works better as a
play than a book the problems are less
annoying in the play I mean I've read it
and I highly suspect that I highly
suspect it that would be the case
because I remember reading it and
thinking I bet you on stage this looks
phenomenal cuz it's very clear reading
the stage directions it is a spectacle
show the way something like wicked or
Phantom of the Opera are spectacle shows
and both of those if you were to read
them with a literate eye as a
ripped would not work nearly as well as
they do a stage I suspect is the same
thing for the curse child however they
released the curl the curse child's
script sold it as a book as if it was a
book and so they therefore open
themselves up for it to be judged that
way I'm not even sure how well it would
hold up as a play I do suspect it is
better to see on stage than to read but
even as a play I myself for acts who
writes a for act play are you freaking
kidding me
do you like Billy Eilish I don't know
Billy Eilish aside from the bad guy song
I only know that one excuse me
because the burlesque troupe I'm
involved in did a group number to it so
I don't know her stuff there must be
unique then and not liking the cats and
not thinking the cat sandcastle horrible
I actually like the look of them I don't
know if you're unique your minority
which is fine a cats movie where they
are all Chewbacca's and they all speak
like Chewbacca oh dear I saw a rise of
Skywalker on opening night I gave it an
8 out of 10 when I left the theater but
I get a seven and a half out of ten now
it's the most Star Wars II of the new
trilogy I did enjoy rise of Skywalker
it's very fanfic II though especially in
the third act like the climax is like
straight out of fanfic it's ridiculous
I've been looking up some Star Wars
--use stuff and to be honest the plots
and characters something more
interesting than the Disney trilogy
expect especially Mara Jaden Kyle Katarn
and Liz is super annoyed that Mara Jade
is no longer canon like she's
legitimately ticked by that fact but
like for my part I just don't care I
never have I mean a big part of why I
never got into the the extended universe
was
the Sarandon returneth Jedi as far as I
was concerned not necessarily for the
universe in the world but for these
characters that's the end of the story I
cared about that's the end of what
should be the biggest story in their
lives anything else that happens after
that is gonna feel small by comparison
or they're gonna try and make it feel as
big and that just feels cheap so that's
why I never gotten to the EU that's why
I think the Nuge trilogy would have done
better doing less with the original cast
than they did at least they didn't go
with the original cut of rise of the
skywalker where Palpatine blows up the
Falcon when he does the force lightning
you have a source on that or is that
just latest rumor stuff I did not like
rising Skywalker one of the only Disney
films I've not liked pity I couldn't
help but smile and Chewie got the medal
oh that was that was also super fanfic
II like oh look now Chewie finally gets
a medal for all those fan by boys who
said chewy never got him at like it's
such fanservice that moment okay Luigi
it's such a fanservice moment because
it's something that fans have been
saying why didn't you we get a medal at
the end of the original Star Wars film
but like nobody else noticed or care is
just so such pedantic thing huh feel
free to hate me but Harry Potter or
Doctor Who Doctor Who like if I have to
have one that's what I'll take the
Muppets in Amadeus oh oh that would be
very cool dr. teeth as Mozart
I would say gonzo should be Mozart all
right what do we oh god no oh god what
is that
this is either this is either tutti
frutti or its vomit Oh God oh that's
tutti frutti oh okay
imagine the doctor going to the cat's
planet oh dear God
sorry ray calling herself I am okay and
forgive me I'm not gonna read that
because that is a that is a spoiler and
I'm gonna read it out loud
reminded me of a fangirl changing their
surname to a celebrity's on social media
it was it was a little bit and and I saw
or I didn't see I listened to a podcast
actually today that said for that final
scene it should have been kylo Ren
because it would have fit and made a lot
more sense for him to have had that that
moment at that closer then it would have
for a god I keep losing these things
okay what are we alright that's a pink
speckled again so I think that's tutti
frutti again I think I lucked out
alright pick up these ones I'm dropping
all right get back in the box
you're my favorite youtuber all thank
you
may the odds ever be in your favor
Muppets in Chernobyl I still haven't
seen Chernobyl uh do you think they
should stop maybe Star Wars movies for a
while yes and I think they will for my
money we don't get another Star Wars
theatrical release for four years
they'll stick to Disney plus they'll
bring back Clone Wars maybe there'll be
another season of the Mandalorian family
I mean there'll be the the
cassie and and or series that they're
working on
that's where star wars is gonna be for a
while they're gonna keep it out of the
theaters for a while did your parents
ever have an alt name for you before you
were born
uh no my mother always intended my name
to be nathaniel um because she knew she
was gonna have a boy because my mother's
a witch and she focused her energy on
having a boy and had absolutely no doubt
that i was what was gonna happen so
there's that tidbit for you she did not
have a backup name what's your opinion
with the Jedi voices um
I mean I have my issues with a little
bit if you watch the video I did on the
Jedi a couple days ago in that it the
tone of the moment kinda doesn't match a
lot of sort of what the franchise as a
whole seems to have been saying about
the the Jedi overall but in isolation I
actually really like yeah I think it's
really cool especially how many I
recognized have you watched the His Dark
Materials TV show I haven't yet I need
to uh I've been commissioned to so I
need to get to that that's actually one
of the things I hope to get to this
weekend I think the only extended
universe factor that I think Star Wars
fans should know is the survival of
Darth Maul because he's a character in
the Cinematic Universe
well yeah but his returning him friggin
and like and I know he's became back and
uh was it Clone Wars but like them
inserting him as a solo was really
stupid a really really really stupid
what's your favorite flavor of ice cream
it really depends on my mood that's
that's true of a lot of flavors in
general but um mint chocolate chip is
kind of a standard go-to for me
are you gonna watch x-men
have you already I haven't yet I've
heard enough good things that I might
know promises on a video cuz at this
point I'm not timely with it
so we'll see what do you consider Canon
and Doctor Who I know you listen to the
audios do you consider those Canon so
here's the thing with Doctor Who and I
actually consider this to be the case
with any multi media franchise every
franchise of that nature be it
Star Wars be it Doctor Who be it Star
Trek whatever where it is it appears in
multiple mediums and one is not
necessarily a reboot or reinterpretation
of the other which is what you get with
like comic book movies all of those have
a primary medium the main thing that
they are usually the first thing that it
was so in the case of Star Wars
that's films in the case of Star Trek
that's TV same with Doctor Who so in my
mind those kinds of franchises
everything is canon with an asterisk
basically you rank and certain things
Trump the original are using Doctor Who
is the example TV series is the ultimate
Canon that is what everything else
derives from and then everything
basically ranks under that the books the
comics the audios they are Canon so long
as they are not contradicted by the TV
show because the TV show gets to trump
everything and the reason I treat Canon
that ways cuz that's effectively how it
is for the writers because you know the
the writers for something like the comic
books like the Big Finish audio they are
trying to keep in Canon relative to the
TV show but the TV show is not trying to
keep in Canon
with them so the TV show the people who
make the TV show don't care if something
they do contradicts a comic book issue
or a bit of bigger or a bit of Big
Finish audio because they get to set the
standard since that's how I know it
works in the actual creative process
that's how I also treat Canon oh let's
see
what's your favorite Doctor Who book
that has come out this year I love
secrets of vault 13 I've not I've never
read a Doctor Who book Wyatt why do I
have like hiccups every five minutes I
get a hiccup would you consider doctor
show doctor who shows like Torchwood and
my Torchwood and Sarah Jane Adventures
as cannon yes so long as they don't
contradict the main show which again
trumps to them oh I had I had other
stuff to show you what's your favorite
Torchwood or Sarah Jane Adventures to
her well the the best Torchwood was
children of Earth Sarah Jane I don't
know I never I only ever watched the
first two seasons and I only watched
I never rewatched any of them in his
years ago so I don't very particularly
close to remember a lot of the details
of the Sarah Jane stuff at this point
I'm in the HBO series don't watch me you
should check it out you know I I knew
what you meant I've seen the movie the
movies awful but no I haven't seen the
show yet anyways here whatever they are
ah I got I got the misadventures on the
almost epic tale by Stephen Partridge it
was a very nice person and I also got
volume 4 of rat Queens god this books
fun it's so much fun it's so freakin
obscene opinion on eleven and Sarah Jane
Adventures I don't know because he
showed up in series 3 I only saw series
1 and 2
got some mozz Miraz origin comics for
christmas the last comics I read were
venom from the eighties which is nice
because these are way these have way
more depth yeah I was a big sucker for
venom in the 90s but he was not deep
I think Zack Snyder film of Watchmen is
better than you give it credit for have
you just seen the director's cut
no when I don't care because the problem
with the Zack Snyder Watchmen is that
Watchmen is one of those pieces of work
that was so specifically tailored to the
medium that it was released in monthly
comic books in this case it was so
specifically tailored to play to the
strengths and what works in the comic
book medium and Alan Moore particularly
at that point in time understood comics
in a way almost nobody else including
Alan Moore now has understood comics
before or since
what they were capable of what you could
do with them what worked how things
flowed you need to realize an Alan Moore
comic strip was not just the dial I was
like and this kind of happens he would
detail literally everything on the panel
down to a little thing in the corner
with exact writing on a headline in a
newspaper that is how exact Alan Moore
scripted Watchmen that thing is dense as
hell in a way that does not properly
translate to film and here is why I do
not like in fact I kind of hate the Zack
sign or Watchmen movie it is so slavish
to the original text and you think that
would preserve it but it doesn't because
that original work was not meant to be a
film and when you translate it that
directly the things that were tailored
to the original medium now don't
function as well and they didn't have
the balls to say we have to change this
to make it work as a film and maybe
there would have been no way to properly
change it to have a work
film and still have it be identifiable
as Watchmen that is a distinct
possibility in which case from any
artistic perspective you don't make that
film it's a lot it's very in-depth for
me to explain exactly how watchman's
slavish ness screws up the story in
terms of it being an adaptation however
I will give you a Westin Buller example
from another movie to demonstrate what
I'm talking about into the woods okay
William I do see it give me a minute I'm
on a roll here
into the woods was originally a play and
then it was a film released to theaters
now that play was designed for staged in
a very specific way because it took
advantage of a specific thing that
happens in theatre that doesn't happen
in any other medium anymore
that's the intermission the way that
play was written was written and
intended and designed is act one ends
and it ends in a big happily ever after
song the play is about fairy tales and
it has Rapunzel and the big bad wolf and
all these things you know going on and
everything seems like it's not a happy
ending and then there's the act break so
you have intermission you get up you
stretch you go to the bathroom and
during the intermission you go wait a
minute and it sinks in if that was the
happy ending what's going on what's
gonna happen in act 2 and it prepares
you for the severe gear shift that story
takes in act 2 whereas when they made
the film there's no intermission there's
nothing to cushion the gear shift and
it's just jarring as hell because the
original was tailored to the medium it
was originally told in and when they
adapted it to film they kept something
intended to work in another medium that
doesn't work in film and I use that
example because that's a much simpler
one that I can do rather than trying to
tag a watch them because Watchmen is
complicated and so exceptionally dense
to try and explain it you have to go
back and analyze the original thing
which
much smarter people than me I've spent
literally hours doing well I would say
you know weeks months years doing in
hours worth of videos or podcasts or
what-have-you but that in a nutshell
even though I mean using an example from
another film that in a nutshell is why I
hate Watchmen okay there we go
oh boy the movies and TV shows do you
buy DVDs or blu-rays or do you prefer
digital media streaming live boo do
Netflix Hulu etc I'm perfectly happy
with streaming if I like something
enough that I want to ensure that I can
watch it whenever I want to in the
future I will get it physically so like
for example I had this on my Christmas
wish list
I did get Doctor Who series 11 which for
all my reservations about it I wanted to
be sure I had that's my one problem with
digital media it can vanish if you don't
own it physically oh my god it can be
taken away from you and I hate that like
on principle I hate that so okay I'm
gonna shake it again cuz I look uh no
that's either gonna be lemon or here wax
Oh
God judge your work for them
Oh God
Oh actually I think the woods movie
thanks undercut my point
do you miss appointment television all I
really don't I never liked that uh we
were tux or something in that one
reviewing spy fault no I don't know what
it tux if I did I totally would but I
don't uh have you seen the Tenth Doctor
meets the Muppets on stage yes I have
seen now it's not on that earlier this
year somebody sent me a link to it okay
here we go ah I swear to God if I get
another earwax
huh oh that looks like watermelon
oh that's watermelon I don't even like
watermelon is a jelly bean flavor but
that's just a relief huh what is the
most surprisingly good thing movies
books whatever you've been commissioned
to do um surprisingly good was tightened
season one of Titans I didn't think I
was gonna like him the guy who
commissioned me to review it didn't
think I was gonna like it
he actually basically paid me to rip
into it but I didn't and I ended up
really enjoying it
that one was surprising there were more
than a few they were like I've never
even heard of this and you know but
that's not that's less surprising
because I didn't have any reason to
believe they wouldn't be good but Titans
I did not think was going to be good and
I really did like that first season I
still haven't seen the second one but
what can you do I wish green apple
flavor was in Bertie Botts I think it is
yeah because the green ones are either
grass or green apple I'd love to see you
in it sucks honestly I kind of like to
see me in a tux got Titan season 1 for
xmas cool if you tried talking with
frogs yet yes
actually I had a co-worker give me one
of those before any upcoming classic ku
reviews for the podcast yes I am I am
now behind it's gonna be a black orchid
but I haven't gotten to it yet if yellow
doctor who makes it work better than
then Star Wars and Star Trek media
because of the wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey
stuff aspect I mean that helps but that
just has to do with how pedantic your
fan base is and I think just because
doctor who plays a little bit more fast
and loose especially then something like
say Star Trek does I think the fans are
a bit more forgiving how'd it be a
moderator all I need to do is ask if I
can be one a little more to it than that
because the moderators I have are people
who I've known for a little bit
at least through the online space and
have reason to trust the audio
commentary for Black Orchid is amazing
I'm not sure I'll get to that but hold
on what else about yeah Oh for my
ancient ass ps3 I had XCOM add that to
the pile of games that I haven't played
and keep saying I will someday I bet you
it won't I've got I've got games from my
ps1
that I never got around to playing
because I kept putting them off or
didn't have time and then eventually you
got a ps2 and I never went back to them
there are also some games for my ps2
that are like that too I've done it
repeatedly now I hope you have a great
new year looking forward to what you're
gonna have on the channel going forward
cheers thank you very much Valerie what
do you think Sarah Jane's reaction to 13
would be I think she probably laughs I
also have a ps3 will you be coming back
to newfound courage yes I need to do a
final installment of that let's play but
again it's it's time I need to get ahead
I need to get ahead of my docket because
like I said I haven't been since the
summer because I had family vacation and
then terrific on in fairly rapid
succession within like two or three
weeks of each other and as a result you
know I I built up a backlog don't eat a
bean if it's nasty I'll feel bad look if
it's nasty I won't blame you but I think
everyone else expects me to but I I had
I I had you know built up in kind of a
backlog you know a cushion to
accommodate those vacations but I
haven't rebuilt that since then I've
been playing I've been like writing
really close to the edge since then if
you have super smash brothers melee
somewhere in that pile I'll buy it off
you are desperate to not spend 50 bucks
on a 17 year old game I do have melee I
wasn't planning on selling it though
would you ever do a little
meet-and-greet I mean yeah I suppose the
oh dear oh dear what is this
that might be sausage that might be
black pepper Oh God
okay um what'd I ever do a
meet-and-greet sure but I mean it would
have to be like this something I was
already going to because like I live in
a little friggin nowhere
so like I'm going to Gallifrey one in
February I know of at least one person
who I know through this and the internet
spaces who's going to be there and I
plan to meet them and hang out I will
see if enough other people are going to
be there like doing some kind of
meet-and-greet yeah but otherwise you
know just look for me on the floor are
you hyped for spy fall big shout-out
from Brazil Thank You Brazil um I'm
because I'm pleasantly optimistic hyped
I'm not quite there but okay huh
I might have been dirt it's not awful
it's just weird where are you from I
live in Northeast Vermont why do you
think it worked to say the Brigadier
passed away in the show and why wouldn't
it work if I did it for another
character like say Sarah Jane um the
thing was the Brigadier it was kind of
it was kind of a case of that was all
that they could do and it shouldn't have
come down to that because you know
Nicholas Courtney was alive while the
new show was going on he made an
appearance on the Sarah Jane Adventures
but you know they were never able to to
get him you know timing health etc they
were never able to get him on for the
main show and that was kind of the law
so um I'm not saying that you couldn't
do some acknowledgement of the passing
of Elisabeth Sladen and saying that
Sarah Jane passed away but it doesn't
feel as necessary because she got to
come back on the show and her character
kind of had her goodbyes at least to the
doctor whereas the Brigadier never did
13 would want that dirt flavoured bean
it takes you away I once tried sweets
that were watermelon flavor but we all
agreed they tasted more like cucumber oh
my cucumbers actually they're the crisp
and fresh cucumber water is actually
kind of amazing what is your favorite
musical eyes the Rocky Horror Picture
Show oh boy I honestly I don't know
where did I put that there's my water
oh uh would you cast Tom Ellis as doctor
number 14 I'm not sure I know who Tom
Ellis
is um but anyway favorite musical I
don't know like I like Rocky Horror a
lot
I like repoed the genetic bull the
Genetic Opera a lot for stage
I love next to normal I want to be in
that place so bad would you cast Charles
dances of the master I feel like
honestly that's too obvious I'd love to
have Charles dance on the show but have
him turn out to be a super trustworthy
and upstanding guy that's what I would
like to do with Charles dance Tom Ellis
is Lucifer on Netflix oh I don't like
Lucifer and I'm not gonna see he's a bad
actor I'm sure he's fine he did nothing
for me at all and it didn't help that it
really felt like he was trying
desperately see you know worm his way
into everyone's heart and pants and I'm
just standing here like I can see why
other people do but yeah nah past
Hitchhiker's Guide and Doctor Who same
universe I actually do plan to to devote
a video to that one of these days I
might I might end up having that be next
year's towel day it's talking about the
connections and seeing and I don't know
if I'll make the case for them actually
being the same universe because there's
there's multiple ways you go about that
once you start looking into the ways in
which
reality functions in each of those maybe
they are it's arguable I mean I'm gonna
I'm gonna tackle that one of these days
what is it Orange what's Orange um
cherry maybe till who plans to watch The
Witcher that's a mouthful okay
I'm really scared this this is vomit if
it is I'm spitting it out and an
apologies in advance
oh ah ah it takes a second that's the
worst part this was the moment where he
knew he effed up yeah i F tup bad
oh it lingers God it's like a really
throwing up cuz it frickin lingers ah
a lot of the different cons you've gone
to which of you had the most comfortable
experiences that easy access easy access
breathing room etc honestly I really
enjoyed Vermont Comic Con but it does
appear that that is over now they didn't
have one it's past year and I don't see
any claims for them to bring it back I
mean that was just that was just really
nice small but well-organized little
Colin I really did enjoy it between
Boston and terrific on which of the
other ones I've gotten to I favor
terrific on Boston was a little
overwhelming
have you seen Gavin & Stacey such a good
show I did about four episodes of Gavin
and Stacey it wasn't clicking for me
I've seen doctor in distress no I feel
like you need a palate cleanser after
the horrible flavored beans
I'm gonna need something do you mind if
I ask your pronoun preferences I know
you've said in the past you're
gender-fluid I'd like to show you
channel of people without misgendering
you here's the funny thing about
gender-fluid kind of can't misgender me
it's funny especially like now cuz on
twitter and things like that i can look
at it and so many people have their
pronouns like just in their Twitter
profile up at the top and I feel like a
bit of a jerk for not having lines there
but at the same time the honest-to-god
truth is their situational that's the
nature of gender-fluid
my sense of self changes and I do not
expect anybody to keep up with me and to
adjust for my internal feelings because
there isn't always a visual cue for you
especially these days used to be not all
that long ago your main cue is whether
or not I wore lipstick which first of
all I get the question and actually
write you fairly regular in the comments
are you wearing lipstick no I've
actually yet to wear a lipstick in a
normal video on this channel I've worn a
couple of live streams but that was like
with full makeup you couldn't miss it
but I don't wear lipstick on here my
lips are just really red but that was
that I used to tell people that was the
clue from wearing lipstick use female
pronouns but at this point I present
blended so often you know hair down
dangly earrings these kinds of things
like and the other thing is I don't even
have a strong preference despite my own
meandering sense of self ah
I'm just not bothered so what I tell
people when it comes to my pronouns is
say whatever makes the most sense in
your head and just go with that
you won't offend me what is your Twitter
at council of geeks thank you for all
your great videos sorry if this has been
asked already
but what thing surprised you the most
good or bad looking forward to stuff in
20
20 um like broadly speaking I don't even
know it's that's too broad a category
how did you decide your name to name
your channel council of geeks well
because originally it was a series of
scripted shorts about three friends and
they were the council geeks and I kept
the name because I liked it and because
i tried to do regularly be doing
roundtable discussions with other people
which got tough to wrangle and at this
point the excuse me at this point as was
suggested by a commenter i don't know
about two years ago you folks at the
council you know the viewers the
subscribers the commenters supporters
and i've latched on to that it's not why
I originally picked the name
but I've adopted that number one
celebrity dead or alive you'd spend an
entire day with mere Niloy at a martini
bar what happened to the other council
of geeks well if you're going back to
the scripted shorts one of the moved to
the Caribbean and the other is barely
reachable through like any means he's
not on social media I see him like down
at the farmers market sometimes he's a
blacksmith and he sells stuff there as
far as the folks who are on the logo
being Pollan because there's Liz who has
appeared some this year then there's
Paul and Ryan and they both had kids
they've got kids I've got a kid
everyone's got day jobs schedule
wrangling is a bit change direction
there after a pause does alcohol affect
your gender uh no interesting question
though I'd never I had to pause and
think about that because I had to think
does it no it doesn't like what I'll
prefer to drink might shift depending on
where my sense of gender already is but
drinking
self won't push me one direction or the
other did Ryan show up at least once
this year I think he did Carolyn I think
he showed up he had the start of the
year best Scrooge the Disney animated
Scrooge why why would you ask oh my god
if in supply fall we get a drunk 13 so I
think if Babu Frick is our God you don't
accept that I will kill oh dear so I'm
actually gonna wrap it up what to expect
during a John Barrowman panel lots of
cursing a man swears very very casually
how old were you when he came to terms
with you that you were gender-fluid ah
alright that's the last one I think I'm
gonna answer and then I'm gonna that I'm
gonna bow out um that is a difficult
question to know how to answer because I
didn't adopt gender-fluid as a label
till about three years ago or so he was
three it's about three but I mean before
that I identified it as a crossdresser
and I came to terms with that in my
early 20s so you know my my sense of
self keeps changing and I have to roll
with it as it goes but I've never really
had major stages of denial at any point
in this whole thing so cheers everybody
freakin beans man
and tell you what if you people got
enough of a kick out of it I'll set the
Box aside and save them for another time
oh god this stuff's evil evil these
things I literally stopped watching the
last episode of the second series ekend
series of you on Netflix for this always
worth that now eat the last beam oh you
oh that's watermelon ah I'm safe alright
beans are being saved moved over there
I didn't even show like off all the
stuff that I got I got new slippers that
I'm wearing um that there was there was
the dog that zan dear made for me look
familiar a little bit it was good stuff
I had a good Christmas as I usually do
Christmas is a good time of year for me
but thank you all for tuning in hope you
have a good weekend
have a good New Year be safe have a good
time but be safe wait wait one more
behind just for me do it for the flying
buffets pay me dude you want me to be in
you pay me but have a great New Year
everybody um enjoy spy fall thank you I
certainly hope that I will
so just remember folks you are beautiful
you are valid you are loved you are the
counsel I'm just running meetings
everybody have a Happy New Year